it is a really fun event for a great
cause
community ambulance is gearing up for
its third annual pull for a cure
money raise goes to the american cancer
society and kendall tenney joining us
now live just outside our studio with
all the details hi kendall
hi denise this year is going to be a
little bit different because the pool
for a cure
is going to be virtual i'm joined by
glenn simpson of community ambulance who
is holding the big trophy
this is what the winners will get this
year in years past glenn
people have actually come out to the
event last year you did on the bridge at
new york new york and pulled the
ambulances across
not the case this year a little
different this year uh you know coveted
strikes again
and and so we've uh we know there's
still a need a very important need and
so we've taken the event we've gone
virtual this year
all right so what are some of the events
the first one going on and by the way
tell people where they can sign up and
we'll mention the
place a couple so you can still join um
all month long there's virtual
competitions that take place every week
pull for a cure lv.org for cure lv.org
and the first one is decorating a bra is
that correct best bra
best bra design right and we're looking
for creativity we're looking for
right an opportunity to spread awareness
about a disease that
you know affects millions and and
touches all of us in some shape or form
that's a lot and then you have uh
there's decorating a pumpkin and then
between that a makeup tutorial there's a
makeup tutorial so i've uh i've been
told that there's a chance that they're
going to do a makeup tutorial on
me on how to properly so obviously this
is a spoof on all the makeup tutorials
you see on youtube
this is and this is all part of the real
men wear paint campaign that's put on by
the american cancer society
uh today community ambulance has
collectively raised almost nine thousand
dollars towards
the cure so it's a very important
mission that they have put out there
and it is for men and women and you can
sign up as a team
right for 200 bucks 200 bucks it all
goes right to the american cancer
society if you don't want to put a team
together and you want to do it
individually 25
or if you don't want to join a team but
you want to make a donation pull for a
cure
lv.org is where you can do it all the
funds go to the american
cancer society they go to the american
cancer society society and they stay
right here
in our backyard to be able to help folks
that are in
in need of that help good for you guys a
community ambulance for pivoting and
doing something different this year
obviously
out of necessity hopefully this time
next year we're out here and we're
pulling the ambulance again and it's
like
it's no longer a virtual event and we
look forward to it and
all in the community coming out and
being able to support the event one more
time the website people can sign up for
a cure
lv.org all right hey thanks for all that
you're doing for the community thank you
appreciate it